[Music]
hi guys I know I said today I have a
film called Sarah bridges hi Jeff
Bridges is a loser I'll be answering
some fan questions apply with the pups
this is the best day there's a part in
the film where this kid in the band is
supposed to be screaming like screaming
my name he's like Jamie Jamie but he was
like he went a little he went a little
off the edge with the rule and there's a
blooper reel somewhere where he's like
screaming profanities he's like Oh James
James and he's like freaking out and
it's the funniest thing you know there's
a lot of great messages in Stara burgers
one of them is definitely don't let
people eat your ears one of them is
don't let society dictate what beauty is
that's a really important warning
another one is there's really cool part
where the bully Veronica and Shannon or
Sierra they kind of get together in
their enemies at first but then they
become really good friends and that's
their understanding each other and I
think that's a huge huge takeaway which
is like yeah someone could be your enemy
but you can't really judge someone until
you know who they are why they are the
way they are and it's kind of hard to
not like someone when you understand
that
[Music]
I have it happened like a year and a
half ago I've met someone on Instagram
and like I developed this like
ostensibly intimate relationship with
them and then turns out they weren't who
they were as catfishing does I learned
some of it during the process of filming
I don't speak it I don't sign but it was
definitely really really quite an
experience getting to know more about
the community and the culture of a
signing I'd say I'm closer to you by
this tail I'm closer to Jamie all my
day-to-day life no doubt and then
sometimes I can be a little PD okay when
I when Mike calls for it a little more
aggressive or more egotistical for short
you're never second best yeah this chick
is so kind and so talented Wow I'm lucky
to be here it's pretty much how that
went and it was like that the rest of
the shoot she does these little like
like these little facial expressions
like no no hmm
it's kind of my best I'm really bad at
impressions
[Music]
I really like the kitchen scene between
Lara Jean and Peter and Peter's kitchen
when they are kind of opening up to each
other about their family history again
the same principle of like understanding
why people are the way they are yeah it
was really great to shoot wine is such
an excellent talented giving actress I
[Music]
used to do it with a my girlfriend's at
first I would like to totally do that
and it's just it was very cute I think I
think maybe once or twice they were in
the script but I say well whoa whoa all
the time
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay relax
this one I got attacked by a dog are
these mastiff babies oh yeah I get
attacked when I was six years old by a
mastiff he ripped a hole in my face so
you could see my teeth my gums and all
the way through my tongue to the other
side there's just a massive gaping hole
I specifically remember him lunging and
like being pulled away from him and then
looking back and seeing him like he like
cocked his head like he didn't really
understand what had happened some people
were like yeah do you want to put the
dog down I was like crying no no he
didn't mean to do it
my parents got a dog for us a black lab
German Shepherd Rottweiler mix them
Mackenzie like six weeks after the event
and then getting another dog like a
bigger dog after that was like great not
a bigger dog you better
Shantaram like Gregory David Roberts the
whole book is very poetic and it's a
it's a journey from deep diving into the
abyss and then coming back from it and
transcending it's changing and learning
and it's a beautiful reading right now
all I can think about is the fact that
they're both making out with my father
I used to suck my thumb too
I used to do it all the time it's a
suckable thumb I'm gonna do this I would
say I don't know I guess I wouldn't give
any advice to the high school me outside
you know what no yeah well I would've
said don't shut down so much after after
kids were addicted you don't like hide
who you are and maybe if I hadn't built
up such high walls who knows what would
have been different but I'm very pretty
pretty fortunate and pretty grateful for
the way that my life's turned out excuse
me you guys are adorable in case you
didn't know okay sorry Kravitz I love
you
where did these puppies so much wire
[Music]
hey shower water and then I like dry it
and just shake it whenever we were doing
like stuff like this so I can talk to
you guys there's like this spray this
like sea salt spray sea salt spray that
like makes it look like I just got out
the ocean it's all fake
[Music]
I'm not really romantic um that's not
true
I can I can remember a time where I like
took this girl back to her hometown and
we like did a whole like week and a half
vacation I've written like a good amount
of love letters for sure I'm sorry yeah
I know you don't want to be here and I
know I'm not the cutest person ever but
I love you it's a play insignia like on
the iPhone when you're gonna watch one
of your one of your your videos on your
your camera roll it's just the black
with the play and circle around it I
changed it because I had a picture of my
ex-girlfriend on it like almost a year
ago and I was like I keep thinking about
her whenever I open my phone so I just
changed it to that and it's great now I
don't even think about it like I don't
even register that I'm looking at a
picture when I open my phone which is
one less thing to like think about a
thousand times a day because you open
your phone to those but these dogs these
beautiful creatures right here are
provided by Vanderpump dogs Vanderpump
dogs dogs org they're adorable
Vanderpump dogs stop stop this is not
acceptable
you do not hump your brother it's the
girl upping the guy I like you killing
it you got a big dick energy you know
everybody heard a thing take energy you
have it
[Music]